Traditionally modern art has been organized, separated and discussed in great length by
time period and movement. We wouldn't be doing
that. These videos will instead look at art
by theme. Places & Spaces. Art & Identity.
Transforming Everyday Objects. And Art & Society.
These themes in an attempt to bridge the gap
between modern art & you. I think that modern
art can meet you where you are and allows
you to work with what you already know. It
says, interestingly, as much about you or
me as it does about the artist himself. There's
going to be pictures, there's going to be
these people, there's love, there's death,
there's this guy, there's this thing, there's
a chainsaw. This is why this museum, this
is why this subject is so rich because there's
such diversity in it. If you find a foothold
and get started, you're never going to finish.
It's going to be another way to look at modern
art. Suddenly, it opens up a greater dialogue
about connections not only between works of
art but to things we already know. It just
gives you another entry point to really engage
with the art that you're seeing.